this is supposed to be the beating heart
of Britain's economy today the City of
London is a ghost city and at its heart
is the Bank of England now contemplating
historic collapse in economic activity
this is a very old institution so I'm
not going to speak for the whole length
of the history of the Bank convenient
but I think it is unique slightly it's
unique in modern times never seen
anything like this the bank laid out a
covert 19 scenario which includes a 14%
fall in economic output this year the
biggest annual contraction
since 1706 though the scenario would
then see the economy rebound by 15% next
year that rebound prompting of raise of
the eyebrows from economists with
longish memories if you remember back in
the early days of the financial crisis a
lot of institutions including the Bank
of England we're predicting v-shaped
recovery so the economy goes down and
then it goes up again in a year or so
and they were very wrong as we all know
about that in a sense the bank is doing
something similar this time around
saying there's going to be a mighty fall
potentially in the economy but become
the end of 2021 we'll be back to more or
less where we started but crucially that
entirely depends on the financial sector
doing its bit the clear message to banks
is that the best thing they can do not
just for the economy that's important
but for themselves in terms of their own
financial positions is to keep lending
and what if they don't well the message
from us is that the outcome will be
worse it'll be worse for the economy and
therefore it'll be worse for the banks
why well consider the plight of
Valentina a physio who simply couldn't
keep afloat without the government's
furlough scheme all loans from banks we
have seen a 90 percent drop in our
revenue we're seeing ourselves building
up more and more liabilities that we are
seriously concerned that we are going to
be struggling to to meet and cover and
say if this is seen as we've been able
to use schemes like the furlough
scheming which has been an absolute
lifeline that a lot of us are having to
go down the route of very difficult
decisions in applying for quite
significant loans and that's not helped
by the fact that even though the Bank of
England has cut rates to just not 0.1%
banks aren't all passing that on to
customers so will this governor do what
Mark Carney ruled out and maybe even cut
rates into negative territory
I think previous people on the MPC and
previous governments would say they
didn't they didn't have in mind the
scenario that we're in today and I think
it's wise not to rule anything off the
table unlikely as it is it's striking
that unprecedented remedies are on the
table and with the UK facing an
unprecedented collapse in the economic
activity with banks being asked to
provide unprecedented support who can
rule anything out
Eddie Conway Sky News